c'est tous les jours Karim Benzema il y
a son avocat qui a encore réagi il était
sur France Info et il a dit jeudi soir
je parlais avec Karim Benzema c'est la
première fois qu'il me disait j'ai
entendu tellement de choses sur moi
tellement de choses injustes mais là
pour la première fois ce sont mes gamins
qui souffrent parce qu'on accuse leur
père d'être un terroriste il faudrait
que ces gens mesurent la violence de
leurs propos parce qu'il y a eu
énormément de de de remous autour de ça
Géraldine tu voulais tu voulais dire un
mot sur ça ou sur Non ça moi j'ai trouvé
que la sortie d'armana pour l'instant
elle est invraisemblable en fait il a a
en pature le pauvre Benzema qui a rien
demandé je trouvais ça complètement
dingue et totalement injuste et vraiment
très pour le coup très dangereux et oui
non je voulais dire en fait vous vous
dites en gros ouais on vit tous en paix
tout ça il faut il faut que tout le
monde s'aime et tout ça je suis d'accord
mais sauf que là on constate quand même
très clairement que le conflit
israëlpalestiniens il il existe chez
nous en fait on l'a complètement importé
non mais il devrait pas mais sauf que en
réalité malheureusement il y a deux camp
et on a l'impression qu'il y a deux camp
qui sont irréconcilibles aujourdui il y
a pas de camp Mo Mo moi j'ai j'ai cette
impression là alors peut-être pas vous
mais moi j'ai cette impression j'ai j'ai
d il y a une défiance et C mais j'ai
l'impression qu' que la société est
totalement fracturée et j'ai
l'impression que les les deux camps on
n'arrive pas à se parler et ça fait
vraiment de la peine et c'est totalement
désespérant d'autant plus qu'on a les
extrêmes qui font tout pour ça avec
Zemour qui les stigmatisse les musulmans
et Mélanchon qui les instrumentalise
donc on est mal barré il y a pas que ça
il y a aussi l'atmosphère des médias et
moi là actuellement je suis t al à ce
momentlà vous nous mettez aussi dans la
sauce parce que nous on entend tous les
so c'est une affaire de justice il faut
de la justice les pour et les cont
mais vous êtes leama là vous êtes mignon
AC tout respect j'ai pour vous ce pays
que j'aime quand vous RZ les médias mais
il y a qu'une parole le la seule
personne qui trouve entre guillemets
musulman il vous ramène un imam qui
s'appelle chaloubi
chou en cours de français au fond de la
classe qui est habillé comme un mec qui
arrive à Marseille en 1962 avec ses
Valis et ses 15 gamins et qui est censé
représenter mais expliquezmo représente
pas moi mais alors expliquez-moi ben
justement ça m'intéresse
BFM même sur France tél télévision
publque il y a que des gens voilà on a
l'impression qu'onexiste pas mais on
existe on est 10 millions on est là on
est là depuis 180 ans on est français
arrêtez d'avoir peur on vous aime j'aime
ce pays je donnerai ma vie demain pour
ce pays mes neveux donner leur vie pour
ce pays mais expquez-moi mais
écoutez-moi du coup oui pardon excuse
parce que cette imam j'en parle souvent
moi dans l'émission parce que je trouve
qu'il a une parole justement très
républicaine et ça me PLA beaucoup mais
attz mais alors pourquoi il vous r si je
peux me
permettre non mais juste non mais il
faut que tu saches un truc c'est que 95
% des musulmans n'adèrent pas du tout à
cet
im moi personne exp pouri ma mère
personne ne me représente je suis comme
lui donc voilà aujourd'hui voilà les
gens n'aiment pas son courant sa façon
d'être sa façon de se présenter sa
façonux dire pour
pas
spécialiste mais moi non plus jeis
laisse g nous le dire en ouais pardon il
a tendance il a tendance à dire c'est
moi monsieur chalgoumi qui représente
l'ensemble des musulmans alors que pas
que
ça il est beaucoup il est beaucoup dans
la dans la roue des politiques et
notamment de Monsieur Darmanin lui
reproche énormément ça il fait de la
politique avant d'enseigner la religion
moi c'est ce que je dirais et donc il
est quand même
minorita pardon pouroi pas aimé il est
pas aimé parce que là parce que tu nous
as rien
dit pourquoi il est pas il ne pense qu'à
lui il fait de
la parce que moi je sais pas
TR il est pas aimé parce que il est pro
Israël arrêtons de se mentir même si il
a un peu de compassion pour les pour les
gamins de Palestine même si ça le
bouleverse si ça le touche il est pro
israélien entre guillets ça ve dire quoi
entre guillemets du coup entre parce que
il a quand même du il est pas
islamophobe rassurez-mo dans chaque dans
chaque musulman dans chaque arabe il y a
un peu d'AD palestinien c'est un conflit
qu'on se passe de de parents à parents
de génération en génération après il y a
ceux qui veulent s'instruire apprendre
savoir comment c'est ça arrivé les
acteurs les protagonistes et les antis
et tout le tralala et on le transporte
voilà on redonne à son fils à son neveu
à son beaufère à son frère il y en a qui
le donne bien il y en a qui donne mal
qui explique mal et donc cette personne
là quoi qu'il arrive il est arabe il est
musulman il a ça dans son ADN la
Palestine reconnaissez que c'est
compliqué pour nous enfin moi je suis
pas musulmane je ne connais pas et donc
pourquoi quand je cite un imam on me dit
en gros oh là là tu as cité le pire il
est horrible il nous représente pas moi
je suis perdu je
pas disous la vérité un là tu
vois quand on conna
pas' moi je l'ai dit à ma manière qui
n'est sans doute pas la bonne d'ord
d'accord je quelqu'un compris la manière
de G ex quand je voulais dire qu'il est
dans la route de monsieurin c'est qu'il
est dans la route du gouvernement
français donc effectivement
effectivement dans son
acception Israël on dit parce non on dit
parce qu'il tient des propos non
cohérents dans la religion musulmane du
coup il nous représente pas c'est ce que
je vous ai dit cy bah si j'ai dit j'ai
dit qu'il pas été aussi clairais imam
oui mais c'est ce que j'ai dit il fait
pas de la religion il fait de la
politique il parle pas bien de religion
nous nous on y connait rien je entendu
c'était le seul imam qui était le
lendemain des à la manifestation
quianis av un message de paix donc
message de
paix un imam un message de Pai c'est
maais im c'est TR imam la paix fait par
son discours encore une fois cet imam là
mais on est
français on veut nous dire qu'on
ressemble à ça un mec qui sa'est pas
conjugué le verbe être à tous les
temps c'est petit ou grand moi ça me
représente pas il est en France de on
est en France de mais tout le monde
appelle à la paix il y a plein de gens
que vous connaissez pas qui app à la
paix il y a plus de gens qui app la p
JeanMichel Jean-Michel j'aimerais avoir
ton sentiment parce que c'est vrai que
quand on on connaît pas béatement je
l'ai vu à la télévision je le connais
pas cette image je l'ai vu à chaque fois
j'entends s'exprimer il a un message un
message modéré enfin une parole modéré
il appelle plutôt à l'apaisement à la
paix à la reconnaissance de l'État de
Palestine mais aussi à la à la sécurité
dont tu as le droit Israël et cetera
donc je un message raisonné et cetera et
je vous apprends à l'instant que vous le
défoncez parce que c'est un mauvaise
image
si un peu vous allez même jusqu'à dire
gen il SAB il est sous protection
d'ailleurs il est sous protection il est
sous protection il s'ab mal je sais pas
s'il est encore il est encore sous
protection mais il l'a été moi ce que
j'aimerais vous poser d'accord
j'aimerais vous poser comme question
parce que c'est la question de fond et
vous le savez bien en France depuis
longtemps c'est qui représente la
population musulmane en France quel est
l'interlocuteurésent non mais c'est bien
de d'avoir ce discours très angélique
mais il y a un moment
mais c'est incroyable ja votème je suis
représenté par personne par mais alors
qui représente comm on cite souvent
choui comme qui vous représente non mais
c'est ça il a raison qui n représente
qui représente lesé
attende je peux essayer de
m'exprimer on est toujours à la
recherche concernant la la la communauté
musulmane de quelqu'un qui peut
représenter avoir un discours quice vous
par de communuté mais j'ai pas de
communauté moi mais
oui K c'est tout ce que j'ai comme
communauté vous savez très bien que
depuis des années il y a un problème de
représentativité de la communauté
musule une religion de l'time il a pas
avoir un porte-parole
de été essayé par le gouvernement ça a
foiré
complèement le Conseil français c'est
pour ça que je faisais référence oui il
faut pas de représentant pourquoi il
faudrait un représentant
parce que parce que lorsquil y a
lorsqu'il y a un imam comme devrait dire
quoi ce représentant vous voudriez qu'au
nom de la
communauté je vais essayer d'aller
jusqu'au bout de ma phrase lorsqu'on
parle de chalgoumi alors il y a
effectivement une immense majorité de
musulmans qui disent bah ils nous
représentent pas du coup on ne sait pas
quelle est l'opinion générale des
musulmans pourquoi pourquoi je peux
attendez attendez attendez n je vais
vous dire pourquoi mais pourquoi les
musulmans d' ça ne représente pas je
vais vous expliquer ça n'a rien à voir
avec ce que vous dites JAC excusez-moi
c'est juste que c'est celui qui est le
plus visible donc ils disent comme c'est
lui qui a le plus la parole dans les
médias et partout la parole de cet imam
ne nous représente pas donc n'écoutez
pas euh ce gars-là parce que il ne nous
représente pas c'est pas on a un autre
représentant et qui n'est pas l'imam
shalgoui c'est pas ça c'est comme il est
il occupe énormément l'espace médiatique
et bien les musulmans disent attention
lui il dit ce qu'il veut mais parce que
dans la tête des gens les gens vont
croire que cet imam là représente tous
les musulmans mais c'est pas ça c'est ça
c'est absolument ça et lui il cherche il
cherche à occuper non
maisis parilleurs dire que c'est un
islam politique je trouve ça enfin que
c'est un imam politique un message
politique je trouve ça un peu dur
gouvernement Fran les chaque fois que je
l'entends je trouve que c'est quelqu'un
qui a un message de
Pai parce que son discours vous plaît
arrêtez il pas un message
de voulez que je vous le dise dans une
expression vulgaire moi je veux pas ça
ce soir d'cord il ne pense qu'à sa
gueule voil cétait ça l'expression à
quoi tout ça pour arriver à ça un peu
vulgaire ah ouais d'accord le gars je
croyais qu'il a il allait lâcher un truc
de ouf mon frère pens à sa gueule quoi
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
oh oh les gars on parle pas tous en même
temps merci
Delphine on va passer autre sujet
intéressant ce qu'il a dit Jacques c'est
important d'avoir des représentants dans
tous les domaines il faut des
représentants chez les catholiques bon
ben voilà c'est le c'est le pape c'est
très bien je voulais a non mais c'est
important d'avoir un représentant
légitime
qui est le représentant des chrétiens en
France mais le pape mais non c'est pas
le PAP en
France
deimam Rabin donne un nom de Rabin qui
représente les Juifs en France le r le R
4 fait bien de
qume grandose conseil c'est quoi son nom
on le connait mais pourquoi pourquoi
devra avoir un avocat comme s'il étaaiit
plus coupable que les question c'est pas
une question d'avocat c'est
que on est dans une sorte de
contradiction puisque à chaque fois
qu'on cite cet imam on nous dit bah oui
mais il ne représente
Pasel pourquoi parce que dans la tête
des gens c'est celui qui a le plus gros
espace médiatique donc forcément c'est
le plus connu donc les gens disent juste
c'est pas lui ne nous
représente parleisamou de la religion
compqu
[Musique]
ce que vous voulez
direéster de la paix pas tout le monde
de chaqueamp
qui fe sil vous plaît s'il vous plaît
merci merci merci merci merci non non
mais c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon les
gars moi je vous moi je non mais je vais
vous donner je vais vous redir je vais
vous redire mon je vais vous redire ce
que je vous ai dit parce que là vous
partez dans tous les sens et on va
clôturer là-dessus je vous dis juste
c'est ça n'a rien à voir avec les
musulmans qui voudraient un autre
représentant ils veulent pas de
représentant c'est ce qui se voit là sur
les réseaux ils veulent pas de
représentant voilà il dis juste que le
mec qui a le plus gros espace médiatique
aujourd'hui en France c'est un mec qui
pour eux ne les représente pas c'est
tout voilà on cl le débatdessus juste ça
on est on est on est ok ok non vous me
dites parce que moi je
dois merci merci merci n d'avoir été
avec nous et verra au club j'espère
bientôt